there is a reasonably convincing amount
of evidence suggesting that it's very
possible that when muscles are doing
this high intensity activity and we are
seeing this acidosis developing the
acidosis might not be you know
catastrophically impacting the actual
contractile function of them the fiber
itself but it might be sending signals
back to the nervous system that the
nervous system of course is responding
to saying hey
[ __ ] hurts down there
things are going pretty intense uh
we're making a lot of energy very
quickly which of course is a threatening
thing to any living organism so the idea
is that there is uh some some kind of
complex
communication going on
with these receptors and the nervous
system that is potentially contributing
to fatigue but from more neurally
mediated uh centers and the idea is that
the muscle fibers themselves can still
work in that ph but upstream there are
nervous uh you know nerve
signals from the nervous system telling
the muscle i know you can work but maybe
don't like some some like central
governor hypothesis stuff yeah yeah so
the the idea is that uh the nervous
system is basically uh
decreasing some of that motor neuron
firing to reduce muscle output due to
fatigue that is being sensed at the
central level in response to peripheral
metabolite accumulation
that that's the one area that that i
think
might help us understand what might be
going on here so it's a lot more complex
than just putting a muscle fiber in a
bath yeah
that's basically what i threw out is
just a wild guess before we started yeah
yeah that is true
um now that's like i said there's two
lines of research i find really
interesting that's one of them i think
it's very compelling if i had to put my
money on one i'd say that probably
explains most of the confusion involved
with acidosis fatigue and buffers as
ergogenic ingredients there is also some
research that i'll put in the show notes
where um
they specifically were looking at the
independent effect this was back to very
mechanistic in vitro stuff
with you know with isolated fibers
so what they were looking at is the
independent effect of elevated ph
uh or i'm sorry elevated uh proton
concentration or reduced ph acidosis
basically they were looking at the
independent effect of acidosis the
independent effect of inorganic
phosphate accumulation which you
mentioned last episode
and then the combined effect of the two
of them
at varying temperature levels and in
varying uh muscle fiber types
and of course as you can
uh gather from that explanation of the
study the results very
nitty gritty hard science stuff going on
here but the very simplified uh result
kind of summary is that the collective
that the combined effect
of having low ph and a lot of inorganic
phosphate had a much bigger effect on
force and power output of the muscle
fiber than either aspect individually
and that effect was most pronounced at
lower temperatures but still persisted
at temperatures that replicate
physiological exercise like temperatures
it was exaggerated in type 2 fibers
more so than type 1 fibers
and like i said that combined effect was
much larger than the independent effect
of either one there seems to be some
degree of synergy there so i think uh
inorganic phosphate definitely still if
i had to put my finger on
one metabolite that is likely to be
directly driving fatigue i would still
put it on inorganic phosphate but it
does seem like there is a synergistic
relationship by which
the acidosis that develops during
fatigue and high intensity exercise that
is kind of working with inorganic
phosphate to produce this uh progression
of fatigue during high intensity
exercise so um it looks like you know
you could look at the more
uh neural route and get some
explanations you can look at some of
these more sophisticated updated in
vitro studies that have built upon some
of these revelations related to acidosis
and temperature um
there is a narrative that is coming
together and and you can start to see
some of the aspects
of how we will eventually understand
fatigue progression
during
very high intensity glycolytic exercise
there's enough here to say i think we're
starting to notice the main characters
of the story a little bit uh but there's
still some work to do to put together
the relative contributions of how this
all fits together
but at the very least i i don't think
we're in a position where we say
buffers work but it makes no sense at
all why yeah but i think we are at a
position where we say buffers work
but it's a hell of a lot more
complicated than just saying if you can
keep you know buffering protons a little
better you know fatigue will be uh
delayed in perpetuity there's a there's
a lot more that seems to be going on
here with fatigue it looks like
buffering some of those protons can be
helpful but the story with muscle
fatigue is very very complicated
and there's a lot of moving parts there
so
hopefully this provides a little bit of
clarity related to our previous segment
and hopefully
my god i hope
this is just one additional little
anecdote that leads you to be a little
more skeptical of content creators who
just
take a mechanism and run with it yeah
and just kind of speculate and speculate
and speculate based on mechanisms
because
you can only speculate on a mechanism
that and and derive actionable
kind of practical takeaways
if you assume that we already know
everything about the processes involved
and that there will be absolutely no
downstream effects you haven't accounted
for and no other moving pieces that you
haven't accounted for so uh we've talked
in past shows about
you know where we fit on the spectrum
between you know how much you rely on
mechanisms in theory how much you rely
on empirical data i think we both tend
to rely a lot on empirical data whenever
it's available because this is just one
additional instance where
stuff gets complicated in the body and
there are a lot of processes where there
are
overlapping mechanisms and redundant
mechanisms and synergistic mechanisms
and most notably mechanisms that we
don't know about yet yeah uh and so
trying to take mechanisms and just say
oh yeah i i have a perfect uh
series of strategies to exploit that it
it it can be done sometimes but it gets
messy